look at what uh Dana White said this
week at the Miami UFC I'm sure you guys
were at the fight he says the
record-breaking number 11.9 billion
million
the last time they were at Miami I think
it was 436 thousand dollars at the door
they went from 436 to 11.9 million break
in Madison Square Gardens record of 11.5
million so let's look at the problem
here's the problem watch this what was
the problem during covet all the
commissioners of all sports were
extremely tight and worried let's shut
down the MBA let's shut down the NFL
you're looking at football games no
one's screaming no one said I can't play
a game like that let's shut down
everything this guy's like nope we're
gonna go Abu Dhabi we're gonna go over
here we're going to go over there and
you and I are getting our source of
entertainment through UFC
what happens all of a sudden they sold
the company I want to say for three and
a half billion dollars in 2017. we can
correct these numbers I think today it's
a
11.3 billion dollar company WWE I think
just sold for 9.2 it went from three and
a half billion to eleven three so
Endeavor that bot uh a UFC just six
years ago has already more than 3xed
their money so he's a driver of a
company as well but he looked at a
problem and he turned that into the
multi-billion dollar company that it is
but do you think and I and speaking to
the UFC as well like they've really
changed the game from a Content
perspective they've brought all these
YouTubers they got they got the milk
boys involved they got these bigger guys
involved where they're having them at
the fights they got they got them making
content was that something that you were
doing with the agency or did that kind
of come a little bit later
so um when I was building the company
this is kind of how I saw it
so what's bigger today Tesla or Elon
Musk Elon Musk okay so let me ask you
Elon Musk steps away from testing brand
wise brand wise I get that but but when
I'm asking okay so go day one okay day
one when he bought Tesla who was bigger
Elon Musk or Tesla
buy a mile is probably Elon Musk at the
time yeah right but today Tesla kind of
has its own identity yes sure right yeah
maybe Elon is obviously a behemoth of a
name because you got the jockey versus
the uh the horse the jockey the horse
who do you bank on this is a
philosophical question right so take
Dana White out of UFC does it take a hit
it has to some extent because it's the
personality is so attached to it the
people that are that go to watch but
maybe not though I know I know where
you're going that's kind of where I'm
going because I think it does take a a
small hit but nothing detrimental let me
give you a number here okay when Apple's
sold yeah and when Steve Jobs died Apple
was 100 billion dollar company we all
thought apple is done with yeah it's a
two and a half trillion dollar company
25x yes we are so emotionally attached
to the founder and the face right I
think Dana's built it in a way today
that UFC is going to live on for a long
time that's a respect from him yeah of
what he's built right so if you go to
you look at Elon Musk and Tesla same
thing so for me at the beginning in the
insurance industry I was known but
nobody knew the company yeah the average
person had no clue why I was because
insurance is such a small little space
Nobody Knows the insurance space so I
said okay the bigger this brand gets I'm
gonna lift this up so today you got two
Brands you're building your brand and
your company's brand this without milk
boys how well does it do
actually think about it yeah well take
them out yeah and sell this product
without milk boys I would say at the
beginning because they are still a very
early company I think it doesn't do as
well but I think that there is a time
frame and I don't know what that time
frame necessarily is but a time frame
where they could step away and happy
that's going to do what it needs to do
no problem but the point the point here
is for anybody that's listened to this
I first fall in love with you yes then
the product yes for sure I first fall in
love with Elon then I say man absolutely
people didn't buy Tesla because they
bought Teslas yes they bought Tesla
because they rep they defended Elon
people bought Apple because they bought
Steve Wozniak and Steve Jobs yeah we're
different we're Rebels we're going
against IBM we're going against
everybody I represent that I'm young I'm
also rebellious let's go up against
these guys right so there's a part of
the brand that's behind it as well Prime
you're not buying Prime because you're
buying if I asked out of a thousand
people that have drank Prime give me the
ingredients out of a thousand people how
many could tell you tell me it is
I'm buying the face but the goal is
eventually for somebody to come and cut
a check to buy Prime like a Coca-Cola
Pepsi somebody like that so today you
got two Brands you build this this one
kind of follows and then eventually this
gets hopefully if you build a right
bigger than you and it has a life
[Music]